foreign
so there's a lot of people
moving on to the next thing there's a
lot of people that like to like police
comedy you know and tell you well that's
funny that's not funny well I've always
wondered what kind of what what do these
people find funny okay have you heard of
this guy named Julio Torres no okay
are you a fan of shapes
in general
am I a fan in the most basic term it's
not a trick question I'm not I wouldn't
say I'm a fan of Shea I mean I recognize
them there we go
so you're not going to like his this is
a clip from his stand-up this is modern
comedy this guy is popular and he got an
HBO special ready Julio Torres
[Applause]
I have a lot of shapes but not a lot of
time so we have to start immediately
I have often been called to Niche to
which I'll say I have no idea what you
could possibly
be talking about
why are they laughing
do you understand this joke I'm not I'm
not getting so basically there's a
conveyor belt going by and there's
things with different shapes on it and
he's it's just is this like futuristic
prop comedy
yes yes yes that's a great way to
describe it this is like what Carrot Top
would be but in the Fifth Element yes
yes it's terrible this is this is the
stand up you would see on the cruise
ship from The Fifth Element yeah exactly
oh guys hold on a second Frozen isn't
laughing Frozen you see he said he's he
said he was Niche right I know I get it
no let me finish he said he was Niche
and then he took a tiny weird chair and
put a crystal on it because
we went over this this morning his neck
shape that I need to show you this is me
coming in late for a meeting and
immediately chiming in
Cactus no no but so the joke is me
coming in late for a meeting I mean
chiming in what does that mean
because he's prickly oh
notice what happens to this shape once
you begin to expand on the same basic
principle of it all of a sudden it turns
into
till the swinton's apartment
how is this comedy this nhbo special
Carlin had HBO specials
I feel like I just this is weird right
like I I thought this was a plank
initially but this is a real it's on HBO
this is a special
it gets worse this is where the guests
sleep
and this
tells them when it's time to go home
[Applause]
presentation that I have also made
their shadows
and their souls
not crazy like me
why are they laughing I don't understand
even when there's bad jokes right even
when there's bad jokes I could be like
oh I get what the joke is right it's not
funny but I don't get I don't even get
what what's the funny what's supposed to
be funny
I can tell you is this is this comedy
for autistic people
yeah I guess I I can tell you why
they're laughing that was recorded at a
different comedy special
I don't think that sounds that that does
sound like it's a python yeah it sounds
like WWE
local chat you guys just don't get it
it's be probably because it's too smart
for you like Rick and Morty okay thank
you Jim see Frozen he gets it because
he's because you see the guys I hate you
oh this guy's in the show you guys just
mentioned off the air that low says
spookies oh I haven't seen it apparently
yes co-creator and executive producer of
it
hi I'm William I'm a comedian and I need
your help to stay in the country
Julio's current Visa I hate Chris
gethard I hate Chris gethard I [ __ ]
cannot understand him he's one of those
Comedians and only people that
obsessively watch IFC would get oh okay
he's one of those
I guess alt you come alt Comics he's
like Brett Gelman he's one of those ones
that thinks he's more talented than he
actually is yeah it expires very soon he
needs about five Big Steve hofstetter
Vibes how's that does that help yeah
thousand dollars to cover all of his
immigration expenses